have you ever wanted to hop in a plane
and fly from the LS airport to Liberty
City well thanks to a modding team it
sounds like you just might be able to
open for has been working on a mod that
will allow you to do just that according
to a blog post the team has been working
on this mod since GTA 5 released on PC
back in 2015 the team said that Liberty
City will not replace Los Santos but
instead it will exist across the ocean
unfortunately if you're hoping to
explore Liberty City with a friend
this is single-player only because
Rockstar does not allow mods in
multiplayer and to avoid any potential
legal issues the mod itself will not
place Liberty City inside of GTA 5
instead you'll have to own both games on
PC a downloadable tool will then extract
Liberty City from GTA 4 and create a
custom DLC pack which can then be
patched into GTA 5 no release date has
been announced for this mod as well as
extensive mod support both GTA 4 and 5
continue to receive official content
updates and fixes GTA 5 recently
received a new mode and a double xp
event while not too long ago published a
rockstar updated GTA 4 with its first
patch in six years for more on GTA 5 and
all things video games stay tuned to
game spot and if you want to stay up to
date with all the latest entertainment
news subscribe to GameSpot universe on
YouTube
[Music]